welcome to another Dr saddler's honest
book review the book that I have here
right now is called Socrates and other
Saints early Christian understandings of
reason and philosophy It Is by darush
Carlovich and it is translated by arur
Rosman uh it's a very short book but
rather dense and you might say why are
you reviewing this book well it was sent
to me specifically by somebody who
wanted to get a review and I think
that's very nice this is the second time
that Dominic escoro has sent me a book
to check out and I'm actually very
pleased with this one for reasons I'll
tell you about in a bit and you might
say given the normal themes you know
applied philosophy ethics professional
ethics leader ship self-help personal
development maybe this is outside of the
sphere but as we're going to see
actually it fits solidly into that in
part because one of the key things that
um uh Carlovich is uh highlighting is
Pier Ado's conception of philosophy as a
way of life now this is also something
for me to read and review as a scholar
because I do work on the notion of
Christian philosophy and specifically on
the 1930s French debates about Christian
philosophy where the issues involved
were probably most thoroughly hashed out
by comparison to any debates prior to
that or any debates that that followed
it involved about 50 different
frankophone authors spilled over into
German language English language Italian
Spanish even Latin discussions that's a
whole other uh can of worms to dig into
so let's jump in and talk about this
book I always like to start off by
highlighting three big ess's the style
of the work the structure of the work
and then kind of a summary of the work
so the style we can start off by saying
listen this is an academic work so you
know you're going to find a fairly
extensive bibliography for a book that's
actually uh you know a little bit more
than 90 Pages including its index um
there are a lot as you can see of
footnotes sometimes taking up half of
the page you know sort of typical of an
academic monograph which essentially
this is but it is readable by a not
primarily academic audience who is
interested in in the questions that are
being raised and to some degree resolved
within this book um there's also
something else that's rather typ well
there's two features that are rather
typical of academic works so there's a
primary source
abbreviations uh what would you call it
you know like a coding in here that
refers to all these interesting works
that we're going to talk about and
there's a forward by another important
academic Remy brog who wrote a um pretty
lengthy about five page forward to the
work that tells you what he made of it
so you know it it is an academic work um
you can definitely get something out of
it if you are not an academic and I
think it's it's worth reading the
translation is by arur Sebastian Rosman
who I don't know but um I would guess
has done a pretty good job here there's
only a tiny number of things where
you're like I'm not quite sure if that
uh was the best translation not because
I can read polish but because you're
like that sounds a little weird there
but it's it's very readable very well
edited I would say as well so that's
quite
important um it is a short monograph so
so this is a work that is roughly 86
pages of full text and then of course
there's an introduction as well so we
we're talking really about 90 Pages
worth of writing so a short study of
something and this leads us into the
structure so it's set up with um four
main chapters and a conclusion the
fourth chapter is significantly longer
than the others and so it begins with a
short introduction the chap the first
chapter is called who's Athens which
Jerusalem obviously sort of a reference
to Alistair McIntyre who's not discussed
in the text at all but you could see
this as potentially being in the shadow
of McIntyre in good ways and then uh we
have uh a chapter called what do Athens
and Jerusalem have in common chapter 3
how much wisdom is there in philosophy
chapter 4 selection and
adaptation and it's going to be oriented
as we're going to talk about in just a
bit around three main questions that are
being dis discussed in the work and uh
there's also in the fourth chapter some
I won't call them extensive but really
solid studies of three early Christian
philosophers Justin Martyr uh Clement of
Alexandria and tertian three different
people writing in three different places
at different times and with
complimentary as interestingly is going
to be argued perspectives on the
relationship between philosophy and
Christianity so it is a book about uh
early Christian philosophy as you can
guess that is the subject matter and the
if we want to give a summary of it and
it's a challenge to try to summarize a
book like this even though it is quite
short in a very short phrase but I would
say if we wanted to put it this way it
might be a little bit
enigmatic Christianity and philosophy
are both more complicated than they're
typically made out to be and their
interrelation and intersection in
something that we can call Christian
philosophy is also more complicated than
people have made it out to be and we run
into trouble
when we demand or desire for it to be
made more simple than it actually is so
let that suffice as a summary of the
work okay so key ideas there's a lot
packed in here into this short little
work um the focus is on what we call the
church fathers and their attitudes
towards evaluation
and even incorporations of and uses of
philosophy prior to Christianity
becoming established as a dominant
cultural Force within the late Roman
Empire so one way of summarizing this is
to use
Constantine as a dividing point right
Constantine the Emperor who famously uh
converted to Christianity and made
Christianity not the official religion
but a legitimate religion and certainly
favored it within his circles and
actually you know took a stand within uh
doctrinal disputes and so we're talking
about a time before say Augustine or
buus in the west and and many other
writers in the East so that's where the
focus is going to be um there's a
hermeneutic here which is that of I
would say recovering and understanding
the
context prior to um Christianity
becoming this dominant intellectual
force and you know way of sort of
running the show you could say and he
says some really interesting things so
this is in the
introduction the questions that he's
asking here not only grew out of my
curiosity about how to answer them but
my curiosity about how to ask them and I
think that that's a very important
distinction there my curiosity was
increased by the fact that the fathers
lived in times when Christianity much
like today was not the spiritual center
of culture is not one of the main
reasons why we are so curious about the
experience of Christians from prec
constantinian times right so there's a
in his view timeliness in a
postchristian Europe including
post-christian Poland uh to asking the
questions that are being raised in here
he also talks about uh mistakes of
viewing Christianity and
philosophy as simple there's there's a
great discussion in here about whether
there really is a here it's there's
actually a section called the problem of
a pure Christianity right and he says
that um there's a debate about um uh we
ties with philosophy poisoned the wells
of the Christian tradition can we say
the diseases of
helenismo of Christ teaching and he says
well these these are not questions that
can be indifferent to Christians uh and
that you know since the Reformation
there's been a lot of engagement on this
uh you know so one one of the questions
he asks for example um was Revelation
betrayed by philosophers who only passed
for Christians and you know he brings up
um harach and his what is Christianity
and he ends up saying listen we're
actually at least in a scholarly Way
Beyond these
oversimplifying
bifurcations um there is some engagement
of some of the thinkers in the Christian
philosophy debates so I'm not going to
assume that you know much about that I
I'll again say that they took place
basic Al from about 1931 to 1935 there's
things preceding it there's things
coming after it and atan jelo which is
somebody who uh Carlovich does talk
about is one of the main people involved
as is jacqu maren close associate with
Jill Sona at the time another really
important philosopher who um represented
another position on Christian philosophy
Maurice Blondell was uh part of it there
were other uh figures on the rationalist
side Emil
breier Leon brunig there were neoc
Scholastics like Fernand Fain Beren Abbe
panito uh Mand donet Pier mandon all all
sorts of other people involved so there
was a wide array of positions there were
even some Protestants who got involved
jacqu ba for example um uh suu as well
from an augustinian perspective and we
could go on and on and on about this one
of the great uh irrationalist
philosophers Leon chesto was also
involved towards the end of the debate
and jilo and shestov are really the only
people that uh Carlovich is going to
engage and and talk about in this but a
lot of what he's saying is gerain to the
the debates that that took place
um there were uh three questions that I
mentioned that he is going to see as
important there's actually a section
called three questions and he says um my
decision to embrace this risky
undertaking is based on my belief in the
merits of taking up three distinct yet
interconnected questions now he's not
going to tell you what those are until a
little bit further on and then he will
outline them so he says um if we agree
the pagans came to know some part of the
truth then one we must ask how it what
happened two what portion of the truth
did they come to know three whether
philosophical knowledge of this truth is
uh needed after the fullness of Truth
was revealed by God and he says above
all the first question is a question
about the causes of the possible
overlaps between the teachings of the
Pagan and Revelation the second problem
constitutes an evaluation of the factual
range of similarities a question about
how much truth can be found in
philosophy the third Pro problem
pertains to the issue of selection and
adoption that is a question about the
usefulness of philosophy and ways of
using Pagan philosophy in Christian
teaching and life and then he says these
are the three domains which as it seems
to me will help best characterize the
stance of Christians towards philosophy
and at the same time they help us to
avoid accusing the theologians of
ignorance chicanery lack of consequence
exuberant in rhetorical enthusiasm or
even psychological disorders and
interestingly who does he bring up there
Carl Young and his study psychological
types um going on a little bit further
um he notes that one thing that we need
to be careful about is um confusing
rationality and philosophy or conflating
the two of those um I think that's quite
true and um it's he's got a good
treatment of what he calls tertullian's
rationalism now if you only know a
little bit about tertian you've probably
heard kredo Quia absurdum I believe
because it's absurd and then what does
Athens have to do with Jerusalem well
Teran wrote a lot and he's not just
throwing reason out throwing the
proverbial baby out with the
bathwater um and so he says being
anti-philosophical is not the same thing
as being anti-rational there's a
Christian use of reason that's possible
um and uh we find
him talking as well this is a little bit
later about um some Christians and he
picks out harack there uh again he says
according to harach Justin's equating of
the logos with Jesus Christ constituted
the starting point of Christianity's
Helen henis ation yet for early
Christians there was a widespread belief
even in tulan that the harmony between
laws of nature discovered by reason and
God's revealed laws does not cancel out
the supernatural or lead to the
Naturalization of the Christian truth so
what he's in effect doing here is
sketching out for us the models that
were being very thoughtfully developed
by at least some people within the early
Christian Community
and taken as helpful even
normative by other members of that early
Christian Community as well and saying
hey if Scholars like harack want to call
this hellenization so much the worse for
them they're actually doing kind of you
know sketchy uh scholarship of that um
there's some good discussion about uh
platonism and
um the role that it's playing we can say
that um here we go this is uh in in uh
discussion about um tertullian and and
others as well he says
um in our search for the Reconstruction
of Works mentioned by tertullian we can
find help in Christian apologies that
frequently featured separate chapters
devoted to this problem they follow
general principles the greatest
attention was paid to those writings
which stress final causes which prove
the existence of the one immaterial and
Transcendent God the least attention was
given to the mechanists atheists
materialists fatalists and those who
deprecated the rule of God's Providence
over the world so who would be the let's
call them fellow Travelers perhaps for
these early Christians so he says these
are the reasons why Plato was so popular
especially the tus the Demi the gorgeous
the Judgment of the Soul or the seventh
letter the inexpressibility of the
knowledge of God it was also the reason
why the stoics garnered so much respect
especially because their strict ideals
of living properly on the other hand
there was a universal rejection of the
atomists and epicurian because they did
not subscribe to these principles so
what we see in among the early
Christians is not just a blanket you
know adoption of well plonus and stoics
good
uh atomists and and epicurian bad
aristotelians who knows exactly where
they they fit in um it's more you know
selective it's more well we like this
about them we don't like this about them
it's more eclectic you could say um a
little bit later he's going to raise the
question of whether philosophy now this
is touching on Pur ao's discussions of
philosophy as a way of life could the
early Christians really really look at
philosophy as a way of life or was that
something that um it was deficient in
right so he's going to consider uh
several different thinkers including
taan who we'll mention a little bit
later um so you know the Christians have
kind of a nuanced view on this uh a
little bit later in the the work about H
well more than halfway through in in the
beginning of chapter 4 um which is
dealing with the third question we see
that uh I'm going just read this this
passage the task of all philosophy
including Christian philosophy is the
therapy of souls who have been LED
astray by the demands of the passions
and false pictures of Happiness by
differing in their opinions about
starting points and their visions of
philosophy's goals the philosophical
schools also differed in their choices
of therapy their sets of exercises for
enabling the soul to realize its natural
Perfection the doubts of the Christians
when it came to the selection process in
no way differs from those of the
platonists parapatics epicurian or
stoics as they pertain to evaluating the
usefulness of particular fields of
philosophy or more widely the value of
the cultural heritage of antiquity the
goal the Telos and the perect ction
teis constitute the V the vistas of
Greek philosophy and are the most
substantial criteria of selection when
the Christians rejected Pagan philosophy
as an alternative way of life it could
no longer be an object of interest in
itself the consequence of ignoring what
I've outlined is not only the abandoning
of the doctrinal frames of Christianity
but also the actual Embrace of another
way of life that is a goal entirely
different than the one proposed by
Christianity it seems to me that this is
how we could understand the utterance in
the famous dream of the great Enthusiast
of Cicero St Jerome who heard the
following bitter words pronounced from
the Throne of God uh cisero not a
Christian right so um philosophy is a
way of life uh adopting that lens which
I know is correct about helps us to see
that there is a great winnowing a great
selection process going going on among
these early Christian
thinkers and that they you know are
involving spiritual exercises and
therapy um there's uh several other
ideas that I want to bring up one of
them is actually coming up much later in
the work uh in the discussion of
tulan and he says that um much like the
majority of ancient philosophers now
this is a great thing to point out
um tertian does not devise a Doctrine
instead he Fosters a spiritual
transformation without losing time
preaching to the choir so this has to do
with why does he talk differently in
different
works like platonic Socrates who
addresses calicles differently than he
does uif and Parmenides altogether
differently tulan adjusts his own
discourse to the personal needs of his
hearer he does not speak to the
alcoholic about the benefits of alcohol
nor does he tell a coward about caution
St Jerome agrees with this Universal
precept about the nature of a moral
education there's no greater Folly than
to teach a pupil what he knows already
so you know different authors even even
sometimes the same author are writing
with different audiences in mind rather
than trying to provide a one single
system of Christian philosophy or
Christian doctrine they're writing a
number of different things and you know
as uh uh Carlovich is pointing out this
is what most ancient philosophers
actually did including Plato even
Aristotle we can say Aristotle
recognizes in the rhetoric the
importance of understanding who your
audience is Cicero does that Plutarch
does that uh senica does that in his
letters epicus does that this is an
integral part of ancient pH philosophy
that often gets left aside when we let
people who want to schematize it and get
away from the actual taxt start um
reducing it in certain ways the other
thing I think is important to bring up
uh comes up several different
times
um earlier on in the text and it is that
the
um uh Christians are
using previous his
attitudes towards philosophy and within
philosophy to combat Pagan philosophy so
he says um we should not forget that the
Christian theologians utilized many
arguments lifted out of the Greeks but
against the Greeks the critique of the
anthropomorphism and immorality of
polytheistic religion was at least since
the time of xenophanes a basic weapon in
the Greek philosophical Armory
the Christians borrowed weapons from
this Armory at will right it's enough to
mention how three important fragments of
xenophanes survived only because they
were so popular among Christians the
theory of emoris of messine arguing gods
were merely divinized humans was also
extremely popular so there are ideas
that are coming up and being used
polemically uh within Greek philosophy
that are then being adopted by the
Christians there's a very interesting
and I think completely correct
discussion here about what tertian is
doing when tertian is saying what does
Athens and Jerusalem have in common he's
actually echoing as uh Carlovich is
pointing out a Roman distrust of Greek
philosophy and culture so he says um the
division of between Jerusalem and Athens
is underg by the division between the
Empire and Athens and so tertullian
inherits all the prejudices of brave
Soldiers lawyers and Statesmen whose
heads were all turned by philosophy the
ambivalent relationship of the Romans to
philosophy which combined an extreme
revulsion and contempt philosophy is a
helenistic disease with wonderment and
adoration can best serve as a reference
point for understanding not only
tertullian stance but also the stances
of many other Christians so isn't that
an interesting thing to point out so
these are some of the main ideas
circulating around in this short little
work I think you can tell that I'm a fan
of this text there's a lot of good stuff
about it I mean part of it is that it's
painstakingly
researched uh very well written very
well thought through uh I think that
most most of the contentions that are
being made certainly all of the big
scale contentions are on point and
actually make a significant contribution
to understanding this early period of
Christian philosophy and Christian
culture more generally I also really
like the attention to the
diversity within uh Pagan philosophy and
Christian response
critiques incorporations of it not all
Christians see things the same way
there's no such thing out there is like
the abstract essence of Christianity
which then we can compare against the
abstract essence of philosophy this is
where so many interpretations of you
know what what the possible relationship
could be and visions of Christian
philosophy went wrong in the Christian
philosophy debates as uh jel s pointed
out as Maran pointed out as Blondell
pointed out as Marcel pointed out so
that's actually I think a very strong
point this grasp of plurality not quite
pluralism but certainly that there is a
diversity and it doesn't mean that
anything goes because you still want to
say well there are things that Veer off
into heresy into
gnosticism into a type of ration ISM so
you know or he brings up pelagianism at
the very end and talking about you know
Austine right so uh I think that's a
real strength of the work um it you know
brag uh in in uh giving a little
synopsis of it at the beginning leads
you to think that the book is basically
just going to be talking about Justin
Martyr Clement of Alexandria and
tertian it's it's talking about St Paul
Augustine Jerome we've already mentioned
some of these taon who's got a much more
pessimistic addressed to the Greeks um
and and quite a few other authors uh
hermus uh irus it's not going into as
great depth in detail as it is with the
big three that it's looking at but it is
it it's it's telling you a story it's
preserving a sort of continuity between
these thinkers that I think is quite
important and it's bring up uh other
thinkers as well like f of Alexandria
who uh gets discussed at several points
um the the fourth part these are really
deep studies even though they're quite
short of Justin clemant Clement and
tertian uh I think they're they're
really quite good and um I certainly
learned some things in the process it's
given me a lot to think about um I I
like the
emphasis on um spiritual exercises and
being able to use ad do I think perhaps
you know sometimes people can go a
little bit too far in thinking that Ado
like is the only person who ever came up
with this Ado himself if you read him
he'll be like no no there this has been
lots and lots and lots of people have
been talking about this including during
my Century but this is a good passage to
read here when we free ourselves from
thinking about ancient philosophy and
purely doctrinal categories
um we can discover a series of
techniques of spiritual conversion in
which tulan like Clement permanently
introduced into Christianity in tulan we
can find all the stoic platonic
exercises mentioned by felo of
Alexandria for example study meditation
cures for the passions recalling the
beautiful self-control doing one's
duties or others such listening with a
constant attention that is focused on
oneself and indifference towards
indifferent things um so this is you
know this is a a real strong point I
think of the work and the last thing
that I'll say is as a scholar of
people's ideas about Christian
philosophy and specifically the
Christian philosophy debates I think
this book is making some small and
measured but still important
contribution to understanding these
these important early thinkers that that
shouldn't be underplayed and probably
should be read more so those are all
really good points about the
work the features that I would say are
problematic are not damningly so but
more on the level of ah I wish there had
been this or I wonder what's going on
there so my my criticisms here should be
taken perhaps with a little grain of
salt um you you know it is a very short
book so it's not going to go into as
much depth as you know some of the other
literature that's out there about the
relationship between Christianity and
philosophy I've mentioned the Christian
philosophy debates I I've also mentioned
that Carlovich only talks about jillo
and shesto and doesn't look at any of
the other authors concerned with the
debates which is that a a deficit to the
book maybe maybe not it depends on what
context we're reading it in but I think
it would have been interesting given the
theme of like focusing on life and
practice had he actually looked at
Blondell um Marcel and Emil braier who
in fact dismissed Christian philosophy
as just being about life and practice
and stuff like that in his earliest
contribution to the
debate um there are a few
infelicities here and there where you're
like H that's that doesn't strike me as
quite
right uh where is this coming from so
one of these is very early on in the
work where he talks about um the
controversy between the Skeptics and the
academics that is a controversy at the
heart of philosophy itself well the
academics were Skeptics so does he mean
between pyonium
Skeptics and then less extreme Skeptics
well they he can't mean that because
within the academy there were debates
about you know um extreme and mitigated
skepticism as we know from Cicero so
that I'm not quite sure what that means
um he also talks about the blindness of
a shest one needs the blindness of a
shest not to notice that philosophy
Greece attachment to a aens in the
academy need not be synonyms for natural
reason but historical examples of a
compromise I gather that the main work
of shesto that um Carlovich has actually
read is only Athens in Jerusalem and not
any of his earlier Works where let's
just say he's he's more skeptical less
intransigent about those sorts of things
so I I'm not quite sure what that's
about there's two things that concern
ansom of Canterbury one where he goes I
think too far
and doesn't bother to provide a a
citation he tells us that
um this
rationalism Finds Its ultimate
expression in the writings of anom of
Canterbury who considers it possible to
prove nearly all Christian dogmas
through natural
reason well that isn't quite what anom
says when you look at his works like you
know the cus homo which is probably one
of the works where is doing that he it's
all kind of provisional and he doesn't
say just natural Reason by itself God is
helping out so I think this is kind of a
bad reading of
ansom uh and he doesn't provide any
Citation for his his assertion about
this he has another thing that he says
that um is about Ansel but he attributes
it to Augustine instead which I think is
a bit of a mistake he talks about um
this latter tradition confirming that
distaste of the apologist for fism both
the
augustinian faith seeking understanding
and the philosophy of aquinus grow out
of the perspective of the fathers with
regard to this matter well Augustine
didn't talk about faith seeking
understanding feden quin's intellectum
that's right out of anel's progan right
he actually wanted to title the work
that so a little bit of a mix up there
but you know uh people make mistakes uh
um there's another one as well um where
ulaa which is um you know typically
translated as caution gets translated as
fear now he's he's he's talking about
Clement so he says wherefore the Divine
Law writes Clement appears to be
necessary to Menace with fear UL laa
that by caution and attention Pro so the
philosopher May acquire and retain
absence of anxiety on eror and m going
going on and then he says this passage
implies says pure Ado etc etc so I don't
know if it's the translator of Clement
got it wrong in Polish and then it got
wrong in English or if Ado got it wrong
and um Carlovich is picking up on it but
it it's Ula is caution so that's a
little bit of confusion there as well um
the only other thing that I think is
kind of an issue and you know it's very
easy to fault an author for not writing
the book that you would have written or
would have liked to have written there
is one really important early Christian
philosopher who fits into this
era and I think who would have
contributed something to this that is
only mentioned once and basically just
in passing and is not explored at all
and that's
lonus so you know he's got his
Institutes of the Christian religion uh
on the anger of God and a few other
works as well and I'm not sure why he is
just essentially ignored in this because
I think it would have strengthened the
work to do this but maybe maybe
Carlovich wanted to just have uh three
you know as a nice even actually odd
number but even uh number for for this
to work with and didn't want to address
lonus so that's all the quibbles that I
have and these criticisms really are at
the level of of quibbles more than you
know genuine oh you've got something
really bad here going
on all right so my final thoughts about
this work uh Socrates and other Saints
early Christian understandings of reason
and philosophy good work
I'm really glad to have come across it I
thank Dominic for having sent it to me
um definitely a book that I will be
keeping and going back to again and I
would recommend that if you're
interested in these questions and topics
and issues whether you're a Christian or
somebody who's just interested in the F
the history of ideas and ancient
philosophy and its engagement with an
important you know religion I think this
is a book that you can
definitely benefit from you know um
Carlovich is probably um I'm guessing
somebody who's quite interested in
Christianity perhaps practicing
Christianity but you don't have to be in
order to get quite a lot of benefit out
of this this
work